so far president putin appears unmoved
by the warnings from president biden and
other nato leaders and that's leading to
questions about whether conflict is
really inevitable here and what's
fueling his possible plans to invade
holly williams is in ukraine for us with
more on that part of the story holly
good morning to you
good morning while the ukrainian
government continues to urge calm the
country's defense ministers told
ukrainians yesterday don't worry sleep
well but a 79 ton plane load of military
equipment tells a somewhat different
story
in kiev last night a delivery of nearly
300 javelin anti-tank missiles and other
munitions this is just the latest
shipment in 200 million dollars worth of
emergency military assistance from the
us
but even with american help ukraine is
still massively outgunned and
outnumbered by its giant neighbor
with around a hundred thousand russian
troops massed on its border ukraine's
fate may be in the hands of just one man
russia's president vladimir putin
but what is it that he really wants
putin grew up in the ussr and worked as
a kgb agent
he wants russia to become like the
soviet union again the most important
thing for him is controlling the
situation
mikhail kordekovsky is a russian
businessman and very public critic of
putin he was convicted on corruption
charges that many believe were
politically motivated after 10 years in
prison he now lives in exile it's
criminal boss
you need to talk with him like with
criminal boss
kodakovsky claims that putin's attempts
to recreate a russian empire are a way
of distracting ordinary russians from
their economic hardship he believes
putin's main goals are staying in power
and enriching himself and his friends
it sounds like what you're saying is
that vladimir putin is the tony soprano
of world politics
i've said this to western politicians
time and time again you're dealing with
a mafia box
if you want advice on how to talk to
vladimir putin ask your policemen
just to remind you this crisis started
because russia started moving tens of
thousands of its troops uh to ukraine's
border yet russia still maintains that
it's the victim threatened by alleged
aggression from the u.s and nato now
some say what's really going on is that
vladimir putin does not want yet another
pro-western country next door and
instead wants ukraine to become some
kind of puppet state
and he's using the threat of those
troops to try to frighten ukraine into
obedience and to force the u.s and its
allies to just let him have what he
wants
nate
holly williams in ukraine thank you so
much